I'm Dolores Huerta and I am 87 years old...
...and I have been an activist since I was 25.
That's 62 years and I'm still going strong.
I do believe that the people that are being affected by the issues...
...are the best ones that can solve them.
We started the National Farm Workers Association with Cesar Chavez,...
...which became the United Farm Workers of America.
Knowing that ordinary people have the power to come together...
...to organize and that they can change policies,...
...this is what really engaged me and really changed my life...
...and eventually, I left being a school teacher to become an organizer.
The pivotal moment in my life came when I met this great man...
...named Fred Ross Sr.,...
...and I went to a meeting where he showed us pictures...
...of people who would organize themselves...
...by registering to vote, elected the first Latino to the Los Angeles City Council.
The most effective way to make changes...
...is by organizing, especially at the grassroots level.
I call going door-to-door canvassing organizing 101...
...because this is where you can really engage with a voter...
...and explain the issues to them.
People get confused so they just throw up their hands and they don't vote,...
...but we have to say to people, vote for what you're confident in voting...
...even if you have to leave some of the spaces blank.
The important thing is to get in there and vote.
We're seeing a new dawn of resistance, a new dawn of movements...
...and if we don't act responsibly,...
...if we don't engage then we have only ourselves to blame.